all right hello out there today is a
very special day on the into the
impossible podcast I'm joined by a
renowned Professor a colleague a friend
who I'm only meeting today for the very
first time Dr Allison Kirkpatrick how
are you doing today my friend
except maybe respond to referee reports
we'll talk about that as well so uh so
today we're going to be talking about
really incredibly provocative claims as
part of what I call the academic media
hype complex where something will get
maybe good good research done on an
important topic
and then what will happen is the Press
office at the institution where the
individual works if they have such a
thing they will uh they will come out
and promote it say because they want to
get attention for their researchers it's
it's a natural thing and it's fine to do
that but then sometimes it gets out of
control and it particular that happens
with claims that revolutionize
threatened to revolutionize our
understanding of the universe or a place
within it
Etc so today uh I am going to talk with
my friend and colleague Allison who is
an expert in Galactic physics and
Dynamics astrophysics I am not I have no
knowledge whatsoever about Galactic
processes other than I can identify
where the Milky Way galaxy is but uh but
besides that it is uh her purview but we
are going to talk about results claimed
from a researcher in Ottawa Canada uh
Rajesh Gupta I believe is how you
pronounce his name and and
um
and I will take the opportunity to have
Allison here to describe what the
galactic physics is and I will talk
about the cosmological implications but
before we start I want to first show
this image that I saw uh from Twitter
which is the repository of all
scientific knowledge right so on Twitter
just this past weekend on Sunday there
was a tweet storm by Joe Rogan
who uh tentatively uh is is going to
host me at some point relatively soon
we'll see more information as that
develops but uh Joe Rogan of course is
the Oprah of Our Generation he is uh
revolutionized our our media and
Communications and he's very fascinated
with science and technology and just
last week he had on a friend of mine uh
whose name is Dr Steven C Meyer who has
been a past guest on the podcast as well
and he mentioned uh you Allison Stephen
C Meyer did he didn't mention you by
name he mentioned me by name so you've
been on Joe Rogan by your work and I've
been on Joe Rogan by name a couple times
and hopefully this will be coming
um to fruition in the near future and
maybe we'll you know I'll convince Joe
to have you on as my sidekick or I'll be
your sidekick or whatever but Joe's very
interested in these claims that the
universe is uh is either far older than
we see or we don't understand what the
universe is made of or we don't
understand how the universe is evolving
and these are incredibly provocative
claims they've gotten so much attention
so you see on the screen now if you're
watching on YouTube I'm showing uh Joe
Rogan's tweet which says simply new
research puts age of the universe at
26.7 billion years nearly twice as old
as previously believe it's a link to a
fizz.org website and then right below it
is a tweet from Elon Musk now I have
tweeted back to both Elon and to Joe uh
to no avail but uh we will we will see
maybe they're joining I hopefully I'm
streaming this on Twitter we'll we'll
see about that you can follow me on
Twitter Dr Brian Keating and follow
Professor Allison kirpatrick at
akastronomy on Twitter as well
um and so what what I wanted to do is
sort of take through beyond the tweet I
want to go beyond the tweet and that is
uh that is to say we should always be
respectful of new ideas that can
challenge our complete understanding of
the nature of our fields and we should
be open to it because a lot of times
Allison I get this complaint you
physicists don't know what you're
talking about Dark Matter Dark Energy
you know whatever uh you don't know what
you're always adding on little little um
you know epicycles how is this any
different and then you guys are
threatened because you're part of big
astronomy so first of all I want you to
take us back back to last summer when I
first met you and that was thanks to a
barrage of media coverage over a similar
claim an Allied claim as we will get
into by Mr Eric Lerner and I should say
that this paper that we're talking about
today is of a different caliber and a
different sort than that of Mr Lerner
who I've you know interacted with back
and forth on various YouTube channels
but never in person and I I should say I
didn't invite Dr Gupta on this call but
we uh we he's welcome to come on the
podcast and we can talk to him at any
other time I've also had conversations
about recent high temperature
superconductivity claims that I invited
the uh the authors of that claimed on
they declined they didn't respond so I
love to have these conversations
although I don't think debate is how
astronomy gets done Allison take us back
July August of last year you were part
of a Maelstrom of undeserved attention
negative attention perhaps and it was
all because of Mr Eric Lerner take us
through what happened back at that time
yeah sure and actually you know what
I'll agree
I look good problems with but it is a
legitimate paper
um and it's got uh it's got a lot in it
that
um there's well thought out
uh but okay so so last summer
I'm on one of the teams that's getting
some of the First Data from the James
Webb Space Telescope or jwst and
um and the things that we find are
really surprising and the things that we
find are what what motivates this paper
today uh we're seeing galaxies in the
very very early universe
um that appear to be pretty massive and
it was it was surprising and it's really
exciting
um I I love it every time we get a
surprising result it's great and I got
interviewed for a nature piece
and I said
um that right now I find myself lying
awake at three in the morning wondering
if everything I've ever done is wrong
um which is true I did we were we were
rethinking everything but not
the Big Bang not like our understanding
of the universe we were rethinking the
parts that we don't understand so well
which is how galaxies form and evolve
that's uh that's an area of
of just really rich ongoing scientific
discovery
um
so so that's what I meant and Eric
Lerner uh does not think that the Big
Bang happened
um and and for those of you out there
um I guess the competing model so
there's two
I don't really want to say competing
because
um the other model doesn't have as much
scientific legitimacy but his story
there have been two competing models
there is the Big Bang which basically
means the universe had a start so the
universe had a start and it is changing
in time so when you hear the Big Bang
that's what you should think of
um
I don't know uh Brian if you've ever
talked about this on on your channel
before but the term Big Bang uh was
actually started as a derogatory term
yeah and you know and nowadays people
are like there's just explosion no no
just the universe had to start and it's
evolving and it's changing
um and then there's the steady state
model which says that the Universe
didn't have a start and it's not
changing uh and so Eric Lerner is a
proponent proponent of the steady state
model
um and uh presented some very spurious
evidence
um Brian has a great video on this that
I watched last year if you haven't seen
it go back and find it it's awesome
um very serious evidence that uh the
disproved the Big Bang uh it did not doc
hasn't done that and it's not even
capable of doing that that is not what
it's looking at uh it is looking at how
galaxies form
uh and and he used my quote and he uh
used my quote
um and used it to imply that I thought
that the Big Bang didn't happen which
isn't true I definitely believe the
universe had a start and it's been
expanding and changing ever since
um
and yeah since then I guess I've become
one of the leading cosmologists
theorists in uh in astronomy which is
not the science that I do at all
congratulations
um we'd love to have you we'd love to
convert you you know
bizarre experience
um I got to be live on the air on
Canadian on a Canadian radio morning
show
um talking talking about this so it's
been pretty fun uh but jwst has not
disproved the big bang and it cannot
disprove the Big Bang that's that's not
what it's that's not what it's doing
that's right yeah and I guess I uh let
me let me you know pull out this analogy
on you and you can smack me down as you
see fit but but it's as if you know we
saw life on Earth that emerged there's
so-called great oxidation event then
there's this Cambrian explosion
and imagine if someone were to observe
these paleontological formations and
from them say no no there's too much
Rich structure in the archaeological
record for a 4.32 billion year old Earth
so in fact uh not only is the earth
never formed it was uh it's been
existing for all time in order to make
it compatible uh with the our models of
of evolutionary
biology so what do you think about that
analogy because essentially what they're
looking at they're looking at size of
shapes applying a 100 year old test
called the Tolman test that we'll get
into which Tolman himself used as a
proof that the Big Bang was correct
um so what do you make of those
at least understand
some things about how the Earth was
different in the past and I think if we
saw a whole bunch of fossils we would
just refine our theory of how fast
animals formed
um the problem so so looking doing
Galaxy evolution is very similar to
looking at the fossil record we
cannot watch things change in time no
grad student lives that long
unfortunately
um I've kept mine alone in a long time
you know
all we get are snapshots of what
galaxies looked like in the past and
what the universe looked like in the
past and we try to figure it out from
there I'm very much like looking at the
fossil record on Earth
um
the issue is and we can get into this
more because this is my issue with the
paper that I want to talk about today
um
conditions in the early Universe might
have been very different and
unfortunately we really can't measure
those and so everything that we're
basing our understanding of early
galaxies on
is based on what we see around us today
in our own Milky Way and our own
galaxies and and we know like we know
that some of that is false
um but we don't have good models for for
how it's false or how can I remember it
yes yes and so you know there's a
difference between the Big Bang model
the components that go into the big
buying model uh cosmology itself the Big
Bang itself and conflating these many
different disparate pieces of data
evidence models hypotheses is very
dangerous and it's the mark of kind of a
sloppy
um you know ham-handed or very
fast-paced attempt to potentially make a
headline or potentially to stake a claim
and uh and I think that well as much as
I like to rail on my fellow colleagues
uh in this case I think it might have
been the you know the media office so
let me let me take you through the the
chain of events as I unders understood
it
um and so let me turn down
people usually complain about my volume
being too loud so I'm going to turn it
down or too soft but now I cranked it up
with my special booster software
um hopefully
flicking feelings up the media office I
mean so for one thing I think it's it's
great that like you have this podcast
and I love talking to the media because
I think it's so important to disseminate
science to people I mean jwst is the
people's telescope it was built with
taxpayer dollars so we should be talking
to them
um on the other hand the media have a
very different job than we have and they
want to make our science exciting and so
that can make things a little bit more
click-baity than perhaps where we're
comfortable with that's right and then
you know I think you have to have you
know apply Newton's law right for every
you know click bait there's an equal and
opposite click bait so you could say
well here's a piece of evidence
potentially against the interpretation
of the age of the universe within the
context of the Big Bang model and then
here's 50 000 other you know pieces of
information and supporting the Big Bang
model and that's why I want to go
through the paper because I think it is
uh it is taking on some interesting uh
some interesting challenges and it's not
to say that the Big Bang model is right
and I always love to quote Isaac Asimov
Isaac Asimov said if you believe the
Earth is flat you're wrong if you
believe the Earth is a perfect sphere
you're also wrong but you're less
wrongful in other words our job as
physicists as astronomers is professors
is to look for the flaws we don't want
to just sit around confirming confirming
confirming that no no we look for the
variations the unexpected surprises and
deviations from what our current model
is and then we refine it and and it's
called the scientific method and I think
it's a very powerful thing but there is
no one scientific method so it can
confuse people by saying if you believe
the Big Bang is not wrong then you
believe it's perfect and that's a very
dangerous syllogism to draw so let's
let's go through the paper oh sorry let
me start with the press release because
this is where it all began at least for
me when I saw this I started off
um looking at it and was a little bit uh
a little bit uh consternated if that's a
word so here's the uh the press release
from you Ottawa University of Ottawa
um which I believe is in the 51st state
known as Canada just kidding out there
my Canadian friends just kidding so it's
called Reinventing cosmology that's
pretty bold right you Ottawa research
puts the aid age of the universe at 26.7
not 13.7 billion years and of course
there's this beautiful picture you know
which is and there's a bunch of quotes
what I love about it is that there's now
a new term for something called The
Impossible early Galaxy problem I love
that like impossible that's part of the
name of this podcast right into the
impossible the name of my second book
Into The Impossible nothing is
impossible in fact Arthur C Clarke said
the only way to go the uh the only way
to discover the limits of the possible
is to go beyond them into the impossible
so we'll be talking about that but in
reality this this paper starts off by by
looking at
um by looking at this quote and the
quote says newly devised model puts
Galaxy formation Time by several billion
years well wait a second that that just
shifted the the play Fields right
um uh oh are you still there continue
without I'm here okay it just said that
it's not got me on there okay oh I think
it just kicked off off Twitter all right
whatever that's no big deal uh Elon you
had your chance to join
um so our newly device addresses Galaxy
formation time so what is what is the
difference here what are they trying to
do they're trying to say that galaxies
are seem to be too highly developed too
structured to be consistent with the big
bang taking place at a certain period of
time and I and I think that is a
fundamental flaw to then say because of
that the model known as the the big bang
cosmology or Lambda CDM Etc is wrong so
what do you make of this conflation and
and then we'll get into the details of
what the professor Gupta or uh Dr Gupta
is claiming what do you make of this
when you combine a flaw and then you say
the underlying Arc superstructure is
itself is wrong because they're things
that are inconsistent with the model
itself go ahead
right so Galaxy information and the Big
Bang model are two separate ideas
um so you know just for everyone out
there we have galaxies because we happen
to have
um a matter anti-matter asymmetry in our
universe and so we happened to be left
with enough matter to form gas and to
form Stars you can have a big bang and
you could not form galaxies at all you
could in fact have an expanding universe
that has no matter in it like there are
two separate ideas
um because of specific things in our
universe uh we we get galaxies
um from the fact that the that
um various things happen very oft very
early on in the universe itself
um but it it's really I don't know it's
really odd to me to keep seeing people
conflate these two ideas because
cosmology is not the same as how
galaxies evolve cosmology talks about
like the big bang
inflation formation of matter possibly
you know what makes Dark Matter
including Dark Matter structures and
then Galaxy Evolution talks about how
the regular matter that we see with our
eyes turns into Stars into galaxies and
eventually becomes the Milky Way
um and those things don't necessarily
predict each other
that's right and when we look at the uh
back to this paper or back to the press
release let me let me just keep reading
from it
um the the question that keeps coming to
my mind is why is this being like picked
up why why is there seeming to be almost
a desperation to have the Big Bang model
which has a a very aged universe as it
is have it be overthrown what do you
make of those kind of in a sociological
sense and then we'll turn to the actual
paper itself which is behind a paywall
but I've I've penetrated the paywall and
I can give tips on how you can do the
same uh out there but let's uh let me
ask you what what is this Fascination
Obsession
Etc going back 30 years in the case of
Eric Lerner promulgating the same types
of of uh proposed or supposed tasks and
why is there so many why are there so
many people out there who really adhere
to this and want to believe it's true is
it like you know believing in aliens
exist or is it something deeper
yeah that's a great question so I think
on the one hand science is exciting and
people and people love science and so
when we learn big results that just
makes people really excited so I think I
think on the on the most basic level
um you have people who genuinely love
science
um maybe don't have
um a highly
um
educate I I hate to say Highly Educated
um but have just like gone on and have a
bachelor's degree in science or have an
advanced degree in science maybe they
don't have that so they don't really
have all the tools and so they're just
they're relying on us to disseminate our
results
um but they love signs that they want to
learn about it and so when the media
disseminates results in a way that's
easier for them to understand but as we
said maybe kind of clickbaity they
really like that
um
but it comes from a genuine place on the
other hand I think that you get into the
less genuine place
um which is
um and I'm going to relate this to like
anti-vaxing and things like that and the
Flat Earth
um I I think there's people
who like conspiracy theories like we
didn't land on the moon and things like
that because
um
because there's a distrust of the
government which may be deserved I mean
come on the government doesn't tell us
everything I'm gonna you know
um and so and so there's this distrust
of the government and then scientists
start getting lumped in with that and
they start seeing us as
um I guess proxies of the government and
so therefore we can't trust scientists
and therefore I found out the secret
thing that makes like everything make
sense
um and so I think it's I think it's an
anti-disestablishment
um
as as well and and that really like that
breaks my heart because the amount that
the government is influencing my science
is exactly zero like even though I take
from the government
um they're not like rubber stamping
everything I put out I can put out
whatever I want right there's no
tribunal where you know people are are
are suggesting that you know unless we
tow the line of of big astronomy that we
will lose our funding lose our students
Etc in fact the way to get you know the
most attention would be to kind of
follow along these narratives and see
where they lead that's why I say in
terms of uh extraterrestrial
intelligence uh you know physicists are
the most interested and most impressive
you know that this is important to study
because if so it's short circuits you
know tenure uh to zero you know seconds
but also because of short seconds our
understanding the physics of the 29th
Century potentially and physicists are
more nerdy and and they're even than the
most die-hard UFO you know kind of uh
believer so to speak so so here's
professor Gupta and his quote as I said
now things start to get interesting
because unlike Lerner this is a this is
an esteemed Professor this is this is a
someone who has a PHD online I'm not
saying you can't make contributions
without a PhD Freeman Dyson my very
first guest on this podcast Allison you
may not know was uh he's known as the
rebel without a PhD he did not have a
PhD but he went on to some success right
so don't worry about you know our
professor Lerner uh Dr Lerner uh not
doctor learner Mr learner but this is
this is a serious person who has many
papers many of which are published in
the same journal and um uh a little bit
questionable you know why this how this
went through so straight to publication
and the and the co-time press release
effectively on what's a model right
Allison this is somebody who's got a
model he's using the model adjusting the
model as he admits to fit the data in
two different ways one is invoking a
very old explanation for the large
extent of the observable universe called
tired light to explain redshifts which
has been going on like I said for
probably 50 60 years and secondly he's
invoking another modification not just
to the astronomical observation of data
and its interpretation but to the laws
of physics because he's proposing and
it's mandatory this happens in the best
fitting of his models which is a
combination of tired light and what's
called changing cosmological constants
or changing constants of nature so in
other words you think of a constant you
think of something that's never changing
he's introducing variable constants and
to do so he applies a bit of what I
claim is Authority bias he cites Dirac
and it is true directed investigates
some of these Notions for various
reasons to explain what are called
numerological problems in physics why is
the fine structure constant so small
um the Drac and many other people wanted
to come up with the fine structure
constant being the reciprocal of an
exact recip article of an integer namely
that it was 137 when you divided 1 by
the cosmological by the fine structure
constant and so he adapted and adjust
that in this paper ad hoc as it may be
uh Dr Gupta inserts in a changing
constant and these changing constants
are all over the place and they're
mandatory for this what did you how did
you react when you saw that I'm going to
blow up the paper and you uh walk us
through what that implication is or what
what you made of it when you first
encountered I found it raised a huge red
flag as the media are of complete
Oblivion to but how did you react to it
let me ask
yeah okay so I'm gonna be completely
honest
um my uh issues with this paper I got
bogged down in the introduction
trying to pass the abstract unlike me
and
um and I and I looked up a lot of his
references and I I didn't agree with
what was in the introduction
um and uh and then I didn't agree with
him using tired light uh at all because
that has been
um and and even I found
I thought it was interesting that he
said in the paper tired late doesn't
actually work
um and so so for people who don't know
what this is this is um light every
Photon of light has energy and the idea
is that as your Photon travels through
space uh it loses its energy
um and this is something that can be
hearkened back to the steady state model
the idea that the universe doesn't have
a beginning so how can we explain
um like things that we're seeing a
really high red shift well the light's
just getting tired and so it's losing
its energy but that's been
um pretty resoundly disproven
um because this this Theory well okay
the nail in the coffin of any steady
state model is that it cannot explain
the cosmic microwave background
um tired light can't do it
um not not not what we see and so so I
kind of got hung up on that
um uh so I uh I actually sorry to
interrupting but but I should say
learner's model relies on that too and
no one since Tolman himself proposed
these tests that bear his name that they
use to substantiate their claims
believes that there's any mechanisms
whatsoever to cause light to lose energy
to exactly compensate for the redshift
Behavior nor can they actually use it to
explain the
um the the patterns of the cosmic
microwave background but yes yeah go on
there are many problems with the with
this so-called tire light model known
for decades if not hundreds of years by
now right
um no actually I would love for you to
point out what the red flags are with
the changing constants
so yeah so there's well the the first
thing that there is no evidence for
these changing Cosmos of these changing
constants and you can get anything you
want if you change the constants because
fundamentally what do astronomers do
we're looking at fossils these fossils
are photons particles of light traveling
through the entire universe since they
were created and in this model unlike
learner's model which is effectively a
static Universe which doesn't change at
all which can explain even more data in
Dr gupta's model there is evolution and
there is redshift and there is expansion
so it's a hybrid that brings up other
problems because there's a famous saying
uh that you know if you give me five
parameters I can fit it to an elephant
and if you give me a six parameter I can
make his Tail Wag uh I think that was
Von Neumann I'm not I'm not sure someone
in the chat room please correct me but
the point being that you keep adding in
these things and it's not just one
constant has to change he goes through
and says all these multiple constants
have to change and what's the reference
for it a paper by Rajesh Gupta from 2022
about globular clusters and so just like
with learner when Lerner first published
his paper the Big Bang didn't happen in
1990 you know two or three that was just
after the first images from the Hubble
Space Telescope lo and behold 30 years
go by you know and a new tool is
launched and the whole point of the new
tool is to supersede what was done
before so he's using you know it's it's
it's it's
um it's not exactly you know there's no
malfeasance that's being done there's no
fraudulent Behavior by Dr Gupta but in
in the end you have to wonder well when
you have one constant vary now you have
to have multiple constants vary again
like entire light there's no
justification given it's just saying if
it does then you can get these results
so if the speed of light slows down then
you can make it appear that the universe
is younger than it you know there hasn't
been as much like time uh travel and so
uh and then if you use other tool like
the size of galaxies which I want to
turn to next because you're more of an
expert you know than I could ever aspire
to be in that realm when we when we talk
about Galaxy sizes when we talk about
the morphology of galaxies to me as a
physicist it seems a little bit squishy
like where does the atmosphere of the
earth end it's not well defined and
multiple reasonable people can have
multiple opinions about that but it
seems like you know when you talk about
a well-formed Galaxy or this the size of
a Galaxy those are almost subjective am
I wrong in that
yeah
um yeah well formed uh I wouldn't call
these well-formed
um for anyone online who's got Google
just look up an image of maisie's Galaxy
um it's a blob uh so yes we are seeing
discs earlier than we thought we would
but we are not seeing discs in the
earliest galaxies
um and one of the things that we like I
said there's a there's a lot of things
we just don't we just don't know in
Galaxy Evolution and so so one of the
things we don't know is is discs and and
how disks form and whether they're long
lived
um and uh so that's really exciting but
that has nothing to do with the big bang
um and you don't need to change
cosmology to understand how disks form
um the size of these galaxies
so I actually did a back of the envelope
calculation because a lot has been made
of the fact that these galaxies are
really packed and
um and their masses are really high
um so let's say that the masses that
we're going to take the mass of these
very early galaxies at face value
um I don't think we should but let's say
we are
um even if we take the mass at face
value the density of these galaxies is
slightly less than the density in the
Omega Centauri cluster
um and so uh Omega so why is this
important okay
the Milky Way has several globular
clusters surrounding it globular
clusters a lot of them we think are the
ripped out nuclei of of galaxies of
other galaxies that the Milky Way has
kind of eaten
um so Omega Centauri is a really special
globular cluster because it has some of
the oldest stars in it it's it's one of
the things that you can use to constrain
the age of the Universe
um because it has stars that are like 13
billion years old so it Formed very very
early on
star formation in the very early
universe everything was dense everything
was
um a lot more compact than it is today
so today we actually can't form globular
clusters we don't form them in the local
Universe
um it's one of the big mysteries of like
well how do you form a globular cluster
they're all old they need to be formed
in dense environments so that's a mega
sen up there um on the screen for any of
you who are amateur astronomers you can
see it
um with your with your eye or with the
telescope
um and so these early galaxies that
we're finding have this density they're
that dense
um and and so they're a little bit
bigger than that so that's that's kind
of surprising is how big they are but
the density itself isn't a problem
um we think that they should have to be
that dense uh to get the globular
clusters that we that we see uh so
that's not a problem and then the
angular sizes
that's not really a problem either
um galaxies should form small
um they should I mean again you're a lot
denser
and we think that a lot of galaxies get
puffed up well we don't think that I
mean we see evidence for it we see that
a lot of galaxies get puffed up
um basically over the last 10 billion
years so we've seen really compact
galaxies before we know that they're the
progenitors of massive ellipticals today
massive ellipticals today are all really
puffy they're very big uh how do you get
that you get that through mergers over
time at least you can form something
really compact in the early universe
and still get something really big today
because then you've got 12 billion years
to interact with other galaxies and
create all those stars and puff up
that's right and yeah so this the
morphology of it and then this angular
momentum problem can you talk about that
I have some familiarity very vague
familiarity with it because of the work
that I'm interested in on the cosmic
microwave background as a probe of
what's called primordial magnetism or
how do you get the first magnetic fields
in the cosmos to kind of spool up
um and so maybe you can walk us through
with the angular momentum problem is and
it is it and where does it rank on kind
of your list of things that that do keep
you up at 3am unlike you know whether or
not the big bang actually happened
um okay wait a second because I actually
don't know what the angular momentum
problem was just how do you get a spiral
galaxy basically at high red shift
they're talking about redshift of 10.
um
um I don't know no one knows
if you form slowly enough so if you if
you're a protosteller cloud collapses
very quickly you're going to get an
elliptical galaxy
um but if you collapse slower
um then you have time like like
protoplanetary discs
um then you have time to actually
collapse down into into a disc
um because so angular momentum has to be
conserved
um but in general momentum has to be
conserved as well and so you're always
forming things in a 3D space uh and so
as the idea is as one particle collapses
down
um from above you're gonna have another
particle collapsing down from below and
so their Z directions are going to
cancel out and you're going to wind up
with an X Y disc uh so you're going to
actually lose your three-dimensionality
um for right now
um there's not a great explanation for
it the best explanation is basically
things just need to happen slowly enough
that you have time to dissipate that
momentum
um before
um through through basically like
interactions so you can settle down into
a disk mm-hmm
so I've highlighted on the screen maybe
I'll just invert us and make the this a
little bit bigger yeah so um here's from
gupta's paper uh he says he's talking
about the tired light model and uh and
how it has uh lacune and flaws and stuff
he says how are the tire light model and
this is for people so the Articles
behind what's called a paywall because
it hasn't been published yet and the way
these journals make money is they make
libraries and universities subscribe to
it so I'm here at UCSD
um Allison
um you may not be at your home campus in
in Kansas but um but uh but nevertheless
we have access to it by virtue of the
fact that you know part instead of
paying you know full wage to my graduate
students and me they pay somewhere to
these Predator no these journals are
fine I've published I've published
papers and monthly notices of the Royal
Astronomical Society anyway he's talking
about this so this is for you know
embargoed I guess uh if you don't have
it but it's letting me as you can see on
the side we did pay for it so
um this is part of our mission of
explaining to the consumer no no cost to
the consumer as Andrew huberman says uh
information that their tax dollars pay
for okay so anyway that's my rant
however tired light models cannot
explain the extreme directional
uniformity of The observed Cosmic
microwave background CMB radiation
there's way more in that sentence than
to actually
um at first glance obvious because the
tire and light model can't even explain
the CMB uh in terms of so they're
talking about the uniformity directional
uniformity but it can't even explain why
it has a temperature that it does
without any there's no mechanism given
to lose energy so what he's going to do
here is he's saying there's the tire
light model has its problems the
expanding Universe solves those problems
but then the expanding Universe has
other problems and though so therefore
let's take the combination of tired
light plus the expanding universe that's
model number one roughly and then he
adopts he calls that Lambda CDM plus
tire light plus TL then he does another
thing where he says well let's take the
expanding universe and add the covariant
coupling constant which means varying
constants of Nature and including things
like Planck's constant the gravitational
force of Isaac Newton Etc so here here
we go he says since Penzeys and Wilson
so it's a little bit misleading to say
Dr Gupta that the uniformity is the only
Lacuna it's actually the isotropic
behavior of it not just the uniformity
which is the anisotropy but the actual
thermal temperature of it there's no
mechanism in tired light to do that uh
never and there's also no mechanism to
to describe not just the extreme
directional uniformity to describe its
anisotropy as well
and there are many many other tests of
this called the sunyai of zeldovic
effect and others that he's just
completely ignoring when he says that
that's the that's the one flaw he's
leading the reader to believe there's
only one flaw with the tired light and
of course he's going to use it
um and he says that in the next uh the
next says he goes Additionally the tired
light does not fit the uh Supernova type
1A data except at very low red shift so
now it's like the old joke you know the
restaurant has such crappy food and they
give you really small portion you know
like how many things are we willing to
kind of accept about the tar light model
and now we're gonna be led to believe
that although it has these big flaws now
we tack it on to the expanding Universe
plus a cosmic constant changing Cosmic
cosmological constants uh that somehow
is the solution that results in the
truth revolutionizing our understanding
of the cosmos and that the Universe
becomes twice as old so you know however
an expanding Universe can easily account
for the observed redshift of distant
galaxies and the cmbi isotropy that's
wrong Allison the CMB expansion actually
the the universe that's it's when the
isotropy was discovered in this paper uh
Penzeys and Wilson they they mentioned
they couldn't see if it was isotropic of
course it's not perfectly isotropic or
we wouldn't be here having this
conversation uh but the uh the best
guess that penzius and Wilson got was
from my PhD advisor's PhD advisor David
Wilkinson and Robert Dickey uh and and
Jim Peebles and that was that the
universe that we observe in the Big Bang
was not a single or event it was
actually the result of a cyclic collapse
of a pre-existing universe so he's wrong
there
um it's not they didn't say that it was
accepted because it explained the
isotropy in fact they didn't observe the
isotropy until 1992. so this is just
completely factually wrong Dr Gupta and
I would expect that you would have a
little bit more care when you describe
such things especially when you have
such huge implications on the Public's
understanding of science but let's keep
going Allison I'm sorry to draw it on so
much I hope you'll interrupt me if I'm
if I'm uh boring you uh but Gupta uh
also in these other papers that
contemplate the existence of tire light
in an expanding universe so he says the
expanding Universe has problems too okay
well what are those problems uh in the
expanding Universe because actually the
only problems that I've heard talked
about are those of Eric Lerner and and
uh and Gupta and others saying that the
formation of galaxies uh seems to be
inconsistent with the time scale that we
thought from our computer simulations to
be required to create these galaxies
with their spiral structure Etc so he's
saying that we need uh we we don't need
an expand an extra parameter but they do
need to change the values of these
constants as they evolve over time and
now we can dive deep because my audience
is the smartest in the known universe as
you are aware
I've been clamoring to have uh to have
you on uh so he goes through the math
and this is this is actually unlike Eric
Lerner's claim which is based on hearsay
and the stuff that you said you know I
called up and and you know and and set
off the cuff and everybody who's an
astronomer knew exactly what you're
talking about by the way and I'm sorry
that you had to endure this kind of
treatment that came up did he ever
contact you
they ever apologize okay
so you're still waiting for that that uh
apology so now he's got gupta's going
through the actual math of it and he's
using my favorite book that bypass guest
uh Barbara Ryden I'll put a link to on
my interview with Barbara it was one of
my favorite guests on the podcast and
also wrote the book that I use in my
cosmology class I don't know if you use
her book but we do here
um and then he goes through and derives
of Hubble uh the so-called freedmen
equations and here's the kind of money
plots here when you vary the
cosmological constants you allow for an
additional term in the Hubble constant
that then becomes time dependent so the
Hubble parameter Uh current time
evaluation of that is the Hubble
constant and he goes through it and I I
believe I haven't checked through the
math although he does cite wolf from
alpha that was a little bit of a
surprise to me but you know these are
standard things that we teach for
undergraduates right so um besides a
press release in the introduction I know
so yeah I was going to mention that but
I thought let's not yeah there's a
nature press release police so there are
a lot of red flags let's take a break
here let's let me reintroduce you
um to the audience because we've got 300
plus people already almost a thousand
have tuned into this uh to this one a
segment that we've done this is uh
Professor Allison Kirkpatrick who's a
renowned observational astronomer who's
dealt with uh quasars galaxies and was
the subject of uh some controversy uh
when it was first announced that the web
telescope saw some uh some unusually
shaped structures in the early universe
that were predicated uh on an age that
was seemingly inconsistent with their
Divine structure so I have my jwst here
that one of my students made for me it
floats through floats through my office
and just a reminder you know we're not
just uh to yokels here so in my second
book called into the impossible uh which
I'm not I'm not plugging but uh I talked
to none other than John Mather uh Twi
many times I think three times times on
the podcast so far but John Mather of
course is the the pi of or the principal
scientist of the James Webb Space
Telescope so we had a great conversation
multiple conversations and last year
when the data first came out the actual
images from Webb he was on the podcast
I'll have a link to that once this
podcast gets edited but he of course you
know measured the cosmic microwave
background Spectrum to be more accurate
than any human made spectrum of a black
body ever made or ever could be made so
we're the two of us are pretty well
versed in this and as I said Allison if
they were to show something that's
inconsistent that's really exciting
isn't it talk to me about what it would
mean let's say let's assume they're
let's let's steal man or steal a person
as we have to say nowadays let's steal
person their perspective Gupta and
learner can you take us through that
what are some of the arguments that
could sound persuasive not just on
Twitter but to a professional such as
yourself
uh yeah so okay I guess the nail in the
coffin for me
we were able to identify a stellar
population that is older than the age of
the universe so this is one of the
common tests to make sure that our
cosmology is correct
um is we look at Stellar populations and
we determine how old they are
um
and with jwst we should have the ability
to do that
um very early in the universe and people
have done that
um and
um and occasionally you might see pop-up
um results they're like oh yeah they
found a stellar population that's it oh
that's over the age of the universe but
it's one of many models that fit the
data and the rest of the models are
consistent and so
um so it needs to be like the only
acceptable model uh and then we would
really have to refine the age of the
Universe
um I think the other nail in the coffin
would be I I know the thing that that
probably excites you as much as it
excites me is like getting a dark matter
detection
um finally figuring out what the Dark
Matter particle is
um or you know it might be multiple
different particles I'm figuring some of
that out because uh right now to get the
galaxies that we're seeing again if what
we're seeing is correct uh you need Dark
Matter to collapse pretty fast and so
what if we find a dark matter particle
that's just not going to collapse that
fast you're not going to form structures
that fast that would also take us back
to the drawing board and make us rethink
things and that could be pretty fun too
but in general there is no there's no
big astronomy I don't have a vested
interest in the big thing being correct
um I go with what the data shows me and
what evidence shows me and so if things
are wrong they're wrong and that's and
that's awesome I mean every time we get
a paradigm shift in science it's it's
great
yeah I agree I mean nothing would be
more exciting than to kind of get
revealed wisdom from something that's
completely new and and in fact to that
end I actually did uh cheekily you know
tweet to our our friend uh Elon Musk who
said uh let me see if I can get his
tweet up here so I mean this kind of
shows and belies the interest and
fascination of you know some of the
world's most you know important
influencers as I as I would uh think
most people would claim someone like
musk is of course he's a genius inventor
and he's the owner of this platform that
you and I met on so he's good for that
right Allison I would have met you
without this platform and everyone
should follow Allison at uh at AK
astronomy uh who's great and actually
your your name on the platform is you
love the Big Bang Allison Hart's the Big
Bang because they were saying you know
she's lost her faith in it whatever but
here's a tweet by our friend Elon and
he's saying the EV so he's responding to
Joe Rogan's tweet that the universe is
this old and he says possibly uh I love
that you know that he's he's opining and
then there's like literally 150 000
views or whatever oh that's a my tweet
but uh so then he goes um possibly but
dark matter is what seems most sketch to
me so uh my kids tell me sketch means
you know sketchy suspicious they call me
suss I don't know uh what that means uh
but I think it's just what kids do
nowadays the kids the youths as they say
but uh but I tweeted back to him I said
look um dark matter is actually known to
exist it's called neutrinos neutrinos
satisfy every condition of a dark matter
candidate they aren't sufficient to
close the universe to make the universe
flat
spatially flat and they can't compensate
for the amount of known matter in the
universe but I said and not only you
know does Dark Matter exist it's it's
well accepted that you know that there
could be either a modification to
gravity or an existing Dark Matter a
particulate Dark Matter candidate I've
talked to Mordecai Milgram who's the
father of Monde and I've talked to Stacy
mcgot my alma mater Case Western you
know we're open to these things that's
not and they're on the outskirts they
are that that is considered a sort of a
fringe belief Sabine hasenfelder a good
friend of mine and and and and real you
know Mentor in terms of things on
YouTube uh she and I have talked about
it there's nothing wrong with it I think
it's interesting but to say that this
discovery is kind of in the same league
uh because dark matter is so sketchy um
how do you react to that somebody says
Allison in the media
um you know like what are you talking
about you astronomers don't know 95 of
the universe's energy budget who are you
how dare you to use Greta thundbergling
how dare you Allison what should we do
what do you say to such a skeptic
um that the evidence is there okay so
maybe the theory isn't complete but the
evidence is there we see evidence
um Vera Rubin
um zwiki Fritz Wiki
um saw this this very convincing
evidence that there is gravity beyond
what we understand okay
maybe Newton's theory of gravity is not
correct that's that's certainly a
possibility
um the other possibility is there there
is matter that we don't know about but
regardless we definitely know that there
is extra gravity in the universe that
stars can't account for
um and so I I just always take it back
to like what are the things that we know
we know the universe is expanding no
galaxies looked different in the past we
know that there are more so I personally
study supermassive black holes
um we know that those grow more rapidly
in the distant Universe than we know
today and then we go to back to Occam's
razor which is what is the simplest
explanation well the simplest
explanation for this is that we have a
finite universe that is changing
um
and then
so
I mean I don't know could we could we
change our conception of the universe
sure but we need to see clear evidence
that cannot be explained otherwise yes
um that's how we get to the point that
we are today that's how you know that's
how Einstein was able to blow apart what
Newton did
um because Newton's laws are correct on
Earth
um but when you start looking at larger
distances you start looking at the way
stars move when an eclipse when
something blocks out the sun
um Newton's Laws can't explain that and
so then you have clear and convincing
evidence that you need something else
and that general relativity happens to
work very well well you know there are a
lot of things that aren't fully
explained right now
um certainly they're a problem like how
do you uh unite quantum gravity with
general relativity that's one of the
things that we don't know but that's fun
that's great we're gonna work on it and
we're going to use the evidence that we
have and we don't throw out evidence
um and we we just try to pick the
simplest explanation and so I guess
that's my that's my problem with this
paper is that the simplest explanation
actually is our
um understanding of galaxies in the
universe is incorrect in the in the
early Universe
um so because because this paper and all
these results keep saying galaxies are
too massive
um for what we understand
um
well that's kind kind of uh number one
those Galaxy masses
I'm gonna go on a limb and say they're
probably wrong
um they're they're probably too high uh
just because again we have to base
how we calculate Galaxy masses on
everything we've learned from the local
universe and that's probably not right
um the other thing is that the very
first results
you're only seeing the most massive the
brightest stuff and so we actually don't
know what the Galaxy population looks
like very early on we've seen like we've
seen the brightest stuff this is like
people if an alien civilization came to
Earth and they wanted to quantify what
humans are like but they only had
celebrities to look at because those are
the people who are on the internet the
most there's a lot of Kardashians out
there you know that's right so all of
humanity is just like the Kardashians
well that's not right those are the
shiniest people okay well
so right now we're just seeing the
shiniest galaxies but I'm on I'm on
another program and there are multiple
other programs right now trying to get
down to the more normal the average
everyday galaxies and so we just we just
don't know yet what what galaxies look
like
yep that's right and so I think there's
a lot of like assuming the conclusion
that's going on in this paper in terms
of uh what a successful Theory would
have to do in order to to be uh
acceptable to be commensurate to be
compatible and so there's a lot of
wiggling in of the constants and so
forth this is well known and there's
there's a lot of different objections to
this not the least of which once you
have those parameters like you know the
famous quote about the elephant with the
six parameter wiggled tail you can also
ask quite well what why do they have
that is it just a pure kinematic you
know uh just just a pure model where
you're basically just taking derivatives
and then fitting to the different
parameters well that's not as impressive
as then coming up with a reason for why
those constants would change so in other
words when playing sorry when uh Dirac
was thinking about variable constants as
as you know as as sort of oxymoronic as
that would sound uh he was still
thinking about those as a motivation for
explaining different physical phenomena
that were known to exist and the
relationship between these constants
with explain things so I want to take
questions from the audience in just a
bit because you've been so generous with
your time but I know we both have to go
in just a few minutes but I think you
know appealing to these you know
authorities like Dirac from 1937 and
wanting to understand the fine structure
constant again his motivation was to
have it fit in and make it basically uh
you know a reciprocal of an integer and
and explain the value of its size which
we now know does change because the plan
they find structure constant depends on
scale it's different at the Quark scale
than it is at the electronic scale but
uh but that's not the type of variation
that he's talking about you have to ask
why is it what is a teleology behind it
so then at the very end of the paper I
just want to give them as due and goes
through it and he has to ask he said
somewhere in the paper that it's you
know the the expanding universe is not
consistent with other men well there's a
lot of pillars on which the Big Bang
stands the CMB expanding galaxies and
most importantly the abundance of the
nuclei which you alluded to in the very
beginning
which can only be formed in a extremely
hot dense phase you know the famous
quote by Carl Sagan that we're all
Stardust
um you know is is not true really
actually most of what we are in terms of
you know by number density uh is
hydrogen which came from The Big Bang
not from uh not from a star in
population two or whatever so um to give
him his do he does say at the very end
very poetic very beautiful jwst is
perhaps playing the same role HST Hubble
Space Telescope did in the 90s
Reinventing cosmology I don't know if
it's Reinventing cosmology but it's
shedding new light with new tools as my
hero Galileo said you know you should
measure what is measurable and you
should make measurable which is not yet
so uh but here we say uh HST put the
Lambda CDM model on a pedestal jws2 is
challenging the standard DJ so it's
almost like HST put it up on a pedestal
jwst is coming down to knock it off the
pedestal which I disagree with but it's
beautiful language in this paper we've
attempted to show the extension of the
Lamborghini with deemed dynamical cos
logical constant which is really a
variable constant which is in in a great
conflict of course with the measurements
that my colleagues have done on on the
uh the dark energy being a cosmological
constant in other words having no
evolutionary Behavior but we have to
test that we can't assume that that's
true so telescopes like my Simon's
Observatory that my colleagues and I are
building Mike Vera Rubin like
um the Nancy Roman Space Telescope these
are all going to tell us new things but
he's saying at the very end it
eliminates his models eliminate the need
for stretching and tuning existing
models to produce such structures in the
early Universe thus amically resolving
the impossible early Galaxy problem well
that's beautiful uh that but it seems
like he's salvaging he's doing whatever
he can Allison to salvage the uh the
Galaxy formation model even if the uh
the Big Bang itself in the way that we
understand it so I find that you can
react to that otherwise I'd like to take
questions from the audience
um so
you can always ask me questions at Dr
Brian Keating on Twitter Instagram
threads postmaster no I don't I don't do
any of those things but uh I I don't
know what a mastodon does to be honest
with you uh but but the point is you can
always contact me uh Dr Brian Keating I
can go to my website where if you are a
student
Allison's has received some of these
Beauties here this is a meteorite so if
you are a student or a professor or Dr
Gupta or even Eric Lerner if you have a
edu address you'll automatically win a
meteorite by going to uh briankating.com
edu and that will get you one if you do
not have an edu you can enter a lottery
to win one of 100 meteorites but of
course Allison being such a generous
thoughtful and uh brilliant colleague
she's already received her batch she
even got a couple of books
um which uh she was she was telling me
about I'm very flattered that you uh
shared uh your book with your my book
with your dad okay so here we go
um we have some questions for you oh let
me let me just first uh highlight can
you mention that you were just on our
mutual friend Ethan Siegel uh starts
with a bang is his handle can you tell
us about that podcast that you were just
on Allison
yeah so that talked about my actual
research uh and I researched
supermassive black holes uh so if you
look up it starts with a bang we go
through the evidence for supermassive
black holes how we measure the mass of
supermassive black holes and um how
supermassive black hole growth changes
throughout the course of the universe
great and he has a podcast and he's also
writing for an outlet called Big think I
believe right
um okay so there's a lot of people in
the audience that say uh that things
like science should not be totalitarian
and that's the main problem with the big
bad we sort of talked about this this is
from a viewer Quan tin I believe
scientific theory should not be
totalitarian and that is the main
problem with the big bang models Big
Bang proponents function like a single
totalitarian party in power that not
allow anything else
um
I'm gonna say something about that okay
um it's not totalitarian it's just
um when you first see the mathematical
expression of the big bang and how you
know the universe changed you're in grad
school
um it takes it just takes a really long
time to build up the physics and
mathematical knowledge and I don't know
if this happens to you Brian
um but as a woman throughout my past you
know 20 years I studied math in under
grad
um I I kind of don't tell people that I
study astronomy anymore because because
every person on an airplane or every guy
in a bar has a theory to tell me he's
like I have a theory of the universe so
tell me study aliens that'll stop it
Allison yeah like no the Al and aliens
Finance you've had you've had zero
physics classes you do not have a theory
universe that has any Merit
um and so science is in like this kind
of big bang modeling the kind of
expertise it takes to write a paper like
guptas
um you need a PhD for and so I can see
people thinking that like science is
elitist but that's why I think public
Outreach is so important
um
because I think it's important to
disseminate results to the public and
hear their questions and what they're
interested in I think that's awesome
um but but actually like refining models
like the big bang takes a dedicated
decades-long study
um of of physics
I would say I actually agree with
um uh with with whoever that Mr and Mrs
tin uh that uh that that scientific
theory shouldn't be totalitarian and
guess what they're not there's no
evidence of conspiracies our job is to
be adversaries as much as I like Allison
if I had the chance to review your your
upcoming paper and I found a flaw in it
I would be honor and Duty bound as would
you with the exact same thing and we do
this on proposals I've I've yet to see
any corruption forced upon me uh you can
disagree with priorities in fact it's
almost like the opposite but there's so
many good things that we would like to
publish or like to fund and to get the
chance to do it this proposal that
you're working on sadly I believe has
you know probably a 10 chance of being
successful if that and it's gotten even
harder over the decades and I think it's
causing a decline in U.S scientific
Prestige compared to Europe um but we
can debate that another time
um talk about have you have you analyzed
web data do you have access to web data
can we get some web data how does it
work cool I've got a lot of web data uh
so I am on I'm on a couple different T
I'm on multiple different teams
um looking at one of the teams is called
NG deep and we are running the deepest
survey so like I said before like so far
we've only seen like the shiniest
brightest galaxies
um NG deep is designed to find the most
normal galaxies
um in the early universe so so I'm on
that uh we don't have clear results yet
um because we're still trying to like
refine refine our measurements
um and then I'm on multiple proposals to
study black hole growth
um
over over Cosmic time and then I'm on
another like really fun proposal
um to to find like the the smallest
supermassive black holes in the local
universe and understand what's happening
with that so yeah I am I'm like drowning
in January yeah so I'm so jealous and
I'll I should say one more thing to Mr
Mrs tin or whoever Ms Ms Tim uh miss Mr
Tim
the proposals for access to web or
Hubble they are double-blinded in other
words you can't I can't give Allison I
can't suppress Allison Eric Lerner
applies for a web telescope time which
he's entitled to do uh Dr Gupta applies
for webbed they are entitled you won't
know it you won't be able to say oh I'm
going to keep him or her down right
there's no way to do that it's double
blind we have no idea who's reviewing us
we have no idea and you can't even put
on that you know my name is Allison and
you know most people would say oh I know
Allison is a girl's name or a woman's
name I'm going to suppress her because
I'm a misogynistic jerk no you can't do
that because your name and even your
past accomplishments which I actually
disagree with Allison I talked with Adam
Reese recently he was on the podcast of
results of previous funding uh you're
not even allowed to say that because I
believe people might use that to kind of
divine who it is so I can see some
problems with that but on the other hand
you would like the users of this 10
billion dollar instrument to be among
the most elite meritocratically served
individual that can best exploit it but
to answer tin's question you know there
is no suppression
um and it's almost impossible to devise
it and if you don't like it Go and
support your own data's public right you
have to make your data public right
Allison
yeah that's right wow yes okay great so
a couple more questions though we both
got a jet um like a Galaxy uh black hole
at the center of our galaxy okay are
there any alternatives to the Big Bang
what do you think is the most promising
alternative to the Big Bang model I
think is what uh pankaj is asking us
here
do you have any of your favorites
I should say we've had on many many
guests on this podcast where we talked
about this so I can yeah I don't know I
would love to hear your answer to this
so uh I just was at the Royal
Institution in the UK and my Talk's
coming out pretty soon it was a very
very great honor for me to give a talk
at the Royal Institution I met many of
you in the audience out there it's
pretty cool at the most uh historic and
longest running of all scientific
lecture Halls Allison it's this amazing
facility in the center of London it's in
a theater in the round it's how papers
used to be presented before there were
journals so uh so give a talk there I
said the title of talk was was there a
big bang meaning the a uh was there many
were there many big Banks and I'm
actually in the office right now with
one of your Heroes I'm sure uh and
certainly one of mine this is a plate by
Margaret Burbage so Margaret Burbidge
took this plate this is galaxies this is
a spectrum She's the One by the way
obviously who taught Vera Rubin how to
do spectroscopy uh uh Margaret could
have discovered Dark Matter on her own
but uh she was generous she let she had
Reuben do it as well but anyway
Jeff Burbage used to occupy this very
office and so he gave a very famous talk
once called was there a big bang meaning
he believed the steady state was true in
the quasi-study state so I gave a kind
of tongue-in-cheek version of that said
was there a big bang or were there
multiple Big Bangs so there are three
leading you know contestants right now
there's something that past guests or
Roger Penrose also a chapter in this
book
um and that uh he has what's called the
conformal cyclic cosmology not to be
confused with the Triple C model of Dr
Gupta in the paper just presently
discussed but that assumes that the
universe is evolving cyclically through
what are called conformal
Transformations that involve the
dissipation and conversion of energy and
and unknown particles of matter called
Dark Matter aerobonds so that's one
model another pass guest and Aegis and
and Paul steinhardt and Neil Turok have
a model which is basically a bouncing
cosmological model where there was
another Universe it doesn't undergo a
quantum singularity so there's no big
bang in the classic sense it does get
hot dense high pressure it does happen
13.796 billion years ago but it is not a
singularity so it's a classical theory
that avoids a single but it's a multiple
Big Bangs that could be more than one or
could be an infinite number
uh there are things like the steady
state universe and um and so you know I
think to take these models you know
seriously or somewhat seriously uh it's
important to ask what are their
falsifiable predictions and that was the
basis of my talk because it turns out
that inflation which also doesn't have a
single Big Bang people think oh
inflation that's just the Big Bang not
really as your friend Ethan will tell
you you know inflation is sort of the
the beginning of the hot big bang phase
of the universe but it's not necessarily
a singularity it doesn't necessarily you
know uh extend to meaning definitive
evidence for zero time Singularity uh
but it also has
um uh infinite Behavior towards the
future in that it creates What's called
the Multiverse where you have multiple
Big Bangs occurring with different
properties throughout the Multiverse so
that's another model and the one that
distinguishes them the fact that the
trait that distinguishes them is that
the conformal cyclic and bouncing models
do not predict a background of
gravitational waves that induce a
specific type of polarization that my
colleagues and I on the Simons
Observatory and bicep are trying to
detect so stay tuned for that okay we'll
take one more uh question here
um uh the Big Bang is unfalsifiable I
disagree with that um you could actually
falsify both inflation and
um and also falsify the notion of um of
the big bang and that has yet to have
happened so I'm not going to answer ask
you that question last question I want
to ask you because you're a renowned
educator as well and you obviously take
great care and thought because you use
my book when you talk no I'm just you
gave my book as a as a present I think
or a prize to the best students
yeah okay I want to ask you about
pedagogy and Ai and what what is your
pedagogical style how how do you teach
it and what could artificial
intelligence is the question we'll be
able to solve all these entrenched
theories could AI is AI used in your in
your work do you use it for any purposes
and can you envision AI or supplementing
revamping re what did what was the name
of this paper again uh it was
revolutionized cosmology uh let me look
at your research yeah it up ends okay I
forgot anyway how to use AI if at all
yeah that's a great question uh we're
using machine learning right now
um so machine learning
um we're using like multiple neural Nets
and the computer is training itself on
basically how to find how to identify uh
supermassive black holes in the early
Universe in galaxies uh mainly because
the data set is is uh so large and uh so
we're gonna need to use machine learning
algorithms to do this uh it used to be
you know in my thesis work I did all
these galaxies by eye I just like looked
at them and fit models and things like
that yeah that's not going to happen
anymore
um and so and and so that's that's one
place where machine learning uh can be
it can be really helpful
um
so in the classroom I know there's a big
Panic right now about about don't say
that don't say Panic remember what
happened last time
um
when people are wondering about
um about like chat DPT for example which
can which which can write things for us
um first of all I played around with
chat GPT a bit I don't I don't find it
very useful
um how do you say I can write my
proposal for me I I you know I wish oh
look I wish
um
but chat GPT is is widely misunderstood
um it is a predictive language text uh
it is not a thinking machine and so I've
I've seen people put questions in there
that they want it to to like solve and
answer and that's not what it does
um it just analyzes stuff that's already
out there and predicts like what the
next thing should be
um I don't honestly you know what
I don't really worry about it when
teaching students
um I kind of think about it like
our parents really freaked out when we
stopped wrote memorization
um because now we have the internet at
our fingertips and the internet is a
tool and so what we need to be teaching
students is how do we recognize good
information on the internet from bad
information
um how do we ask the right questions
uh so we're starting to think about this
higher order thinking and so I think AI
is the same thing AI is not going to
replace our thinking it's going to
recall it's going to cause us to go to
even higher order thinking to understand
how to use AI to our best Advantage
um hopefully automate some of those
tasks that are really boring and take up
a lot of our time so that we can do the
higher order the higher order thinking
and so I think you know I think as much
as AI can help us it's a good tool as
long as students aren't relying on it to
give them an answer and then not
thinking logically about the answer but
that's always the difficulty with
teaching
do you understand what you wrote down
there and no a lot of times they don't
well I'll send you've been so generous
so I'm going to wrap up I'm gonna bid
you a great rest of your evening
afternoon wherever you may be in Kansas
and I want to thank you for being such
an awesome guest
and everybody out there if you liked
Allison you want to see more of her on
this podcast give a thumbs up on your
screen and otherwise subscribe to her on
Twitter
and Allison have a great day thank you
so much for joining us right thank you
foreign
so um a couple words just a channel
Logistics we have a lot of cool stuff
coming up on the podcast including yours
truly
on tomorrow with uh Tom Robert Kuhn of
closer to truth so they interviewed me
about the Multiverse
cosmology my research that's coming out
tomorrow on this channel hit the
notification Bell for that
um I am also putting out a video this
Friday I'm seeing Oppenheimer so if
you're interested in learning what a
real physicist a professor of physics
thinks about Oppenheimer the physics the
stories not the love story so much well
you know who knows let's see if I can
get my wife
uh to you know play the the lead role
she might be seeing Barbie with my
daughters I don't know
maybe I'll switch up maybe I'll see
Barbie physics Professor reacts to
Barbie who wants to see that uh or
should I stay in my Lane
and just see Oppenheimer so I plan is to
have a really deep dive on what was the
physics what was the uh the Dynamics of
the Manhattan Project from the
perspective of an astrophysics Professor
yours truly
stay tuned for that I also have Ryan
Graves uh interview I did about three
weeks ago were polishing it up adding in
some incredible background footage and
inside from him
yeah he was in studio here across the
way where we have our recordings and uh
and he was a phenomenal interview that I
did broadcast live but we've since
edited it made it really really uh kind
of a documentary uh really delightful
piece of work so I hope you'll stay
tuned for that that'll come out in the
next week or so
so a lot of things coming up as I said I
am uh in talks with Folks at Joe Rogan
Experience and it looks pretty likely so
I'm pretty excited about that
um whatever uh you think about Joe as a
as a scientist you can't deny his
cultural impact and the fact that uh
many people including my friend Eric
Weinstein and and um and recently
Stephen Meyer I've discussed my research
both on uh the evolution of the universe
and studying it from an experimentalist
point of view which he hasn't had on yet
he's never into my knowledge correct me
in the chat comments below if he has on
has had on experimental physicist or
cosmologist such as myself let me know
but I don't think he has he's had on
Brian Green Brian Cox why not Brian
Keating and so it looks it looks likely
for that to occur sometime later this
summer and so uh there will be a great
discussion about things ranging from the
origin of the universe the Big Bang the
structures that we see in the universe
the possibility of the Multiverse the
the possibility of a pre-existing
universe and we're definitely going to
get into things like the existence or
lack thereof of extraterrestrial
intelligence limits to their existence
that we can put on from modified
advancements to things like the Drake
equation which Joe has had on many many
guests on including people like Ryan
Graves which is how I you know came to
uh came to really think that this would
be a good experience for Ryan to come on
my podcast Ryan has his own podcast too
by the way anyway
um so it looks like that'll be a go
sometime this summer to meet up with Joe
down there in Austin and uh maybe I'll
swing by Alex's uh campus as well
because I think it's quite fascinating
how much cool podcasting stuff is going
on there in Central Texas home of the uh
of the of the Texas University of Texas
at Austin and soon to be the University
of Austin Texas which I've also had some
fun interactions with my friend Peter
bagazian and and others there so stay
tuned for that the other thing I'll talk
to Joe about is Academia and how
Academia has been uh has modified
changed and what we can do about it to
make the kind of educational experiences
that I want for my audience to make
those very low cost and very high value
and so I've been uh thinking a lot about
that including how we can use AI because
I do think that with some of the tools
that I've developed with my colleagues
and my colleagues themselves are
developing we created the first llm
based on Richard Feynman we're done the
same for Galileo with my undergraduate
students we're going to embody those
we're going to take those into a very
high resolution graphics and then I'm
going to put Galileo in a room with uh
with this guy with Einstein and Newton
and I'm going to ask Einstein to teach
Newton all of general relativity and
then the two of them will start to teach
Galileo about quantum mechanics and
we'll see what they can start to develop
because when AIS can train AIS writing
code there's no telling what will happen
and I think to sandbox it into the
scientific realm alleviates a lot of the
alignment questions and alleviates a lot
of the worries about AI you know
Supremacy and just turning us into paper
clips as past guest on the show Nick
Bostrom talked about
anyway for now there's a lot coming up
stay tuned for Ryan Graves stay tuned
for my interview with Robert Kuhn and
closer to truth coming tomorrow and then
stay tuned for the physics of
Oppenheimer it's going to be a really
fun video I think you're going to love
it so subscribe share the Channel with
your friends leave a comment and stuff
for the algorithm and uh love you all
and talk to you all soon